so i think this is a major trend in 2022
it's saying how long should content be
yes it should be all kinds of lengths
and i think that you have the
opportunity to experiment with different
content formats that meets people at
different places on their journey they
don't have time to listen to today's 35
minute episode of the think media
podcast but when we trim out a clip and
post it somewhere else they get that
nugget in three or four minutes and you
ultimately are serving more people but
remember around the same
value proposition
welcome back to the think media podcast
sean cannell here and uh it's a new year
full of new opportunities and new
possibilities super grateful to be
hanging out with you today hope your
holidays were amazing hope you're doing
amazing and if you happen to be
listening to this episode sometime in
the future you're going to love it
because there's a lot of tactical and
relevant information for getting
traction and growth on your channel and
we're going to get into that in just a
second but today's episode of the think
media podcast is brought to you by
tube1kchallenge.com
our next challenge is coming up soon
five days seven sessions when an entire
youtube studio plus tons of other
giveaways myself and the think media
team are going to be tr they're training
daily
and it's entirely free and so i'll share
a little bit more about that with you
later but if you want to check it out
the url is
tube1kchallenge.com you can always check
it out in the show notes as well but
with that let's jump into the featured
content
[Music]
if your youtube channel is at least 12
months old you have a powerful
opportunity that you can do every new
year and that is looking back over the
trends and the themes and some of the
stand out insights from your youtube
analytics because what gets measured
gets improved and so as we have come
into a new year i looked back at our
main channel think media and i found
three surprising insights from the
highest performing videos on the channel
and i'm excited to share those with you
today the first one
is our most viewed video
was a youtube short
you know i think in 2022
one of the things i would absolutely be
paying attention to is youtube shorts
you know youtube shorts uh started
really this last year as of course a
competitor to instagram reels to
tick-tock short form vertical content
there's now going to be i believe
facebook shorts you know different than
stories every platform wants to jump in
the game with this shorter form content
and i think it would be foolish and
irresponsible to ignore youtube shorts
can your channel succeed without them
absolutely
but is it something that you could
incorporate into your channel or at
least be knowledgeable about i think you
need to be thinking about youtube shorts
you know this past year and to catch you
up youtube shorts are vertical content
right so they're cell phone
framed content vertical not horizontal
like traditional video they're less than
60 seconds you upload them on your main
channel
and they are promoted via the shorts
shelf if they have good engagement and
they can get massive views as i
mentioned one of the trends we noticed
was that okay out of the top 10 videos
of the year our most viewed video was a
youtube short and it received 6.8
million views now this short was created
by nolan mull and it was on an
experiment he did i've seen if anybody
would notice him filming with a camera
that was less than a hundred dollars
from amazon but check this out almost 7
million views
2.1 000 new subscribers
and interestingly enough it actually
only earned 93 dollars from people
watching it on desktop and another 100
to 200 from the shorts fund so what are
the things and takeaways in regards to
your youtube strategy you know we posted
about
30 shorts and they did all right there
was a couple that did pretty well um
they didn't seem to upset anyone on
think media i think if you're like well
what if people don't like the format of
the content i don't know if people care
about the format as much
as they care if it's on brand and
according to the original promise of
your channel like if your channel
promises camera tips camera insights how
to use your camera video video editing
tips like think media does then whether
it's a
a 60 second video or an hour-long
60-minute video if it delivers on the
promise of the title and or you know
whatever is promoted in the thumbnail
then people can choose to watch it or
not and and we didn't really see people
upset from youtube shorts if you stay on
value proposition i think using youtube
shorts or experimenting with them would
be intelligent this year
i think
secondly is if you lob out a couple
youtube shorts as we did you have the
chance of one really taking off for you
and 21 000 new subscribers is crazy like
i think that's the big opportunity is
exposure to new audience exposure to new
people
because shorts have an ability to go
viral like this one did in fact at times
it was driving over a million views in a
day another thing to note about this was
we put the video out but it didn't
actually start going quote unquote viral
for
30 days 45 days then it actually jumped
a couple million views and plateaued
again with slow growth and then it
popped again and started getting another
million views a day for a couple days
and it continues to have kind of a
steady growth and a slower growth now so
why not experiment with youtube shorts i
think it also will help you
get into a different mindset in terms of
how people are thinking and
communicating your message more
concisely concisely i think it'll help
you evolve your strategy if you're
thinking youtube shorts you can use that
same content on instagram reels or tic
talk um and it's something to consider
do i think you have to do youtube shorts
this year no do i think it's worth
considering yes and if your
monetization strategy though is youtube
ad revenue shorts unless you get insane
amounts of views
um is probably not going to bring in a
lot of revenue because again we made
under 300 from almost 7 million views
however 21 new thousand subscribers
have the opportunity to
uh
watch your future videos subscribe to
the channel and connect with you and you
always gotta ask yourself did they
subscribe
what did they subscribe for if you
experimented with a youtube short that
was off brand and they click subscribe
well then you actually might be hurting
your channel because the
traditional youtube videos you upload
afterwards are not something that they
want to continue to watch
because they don't all stay in alignment
so do your best to keep it all in
alignment but why not experiment with
shorter form content and if you want
more on this definitely check out the
show notes and the think media podcast
episode with chris doe
chris du from the future
he uh
uses youtube shorts and he has a lot of
longer form educational type videos
talking about design talking about
marketing your video services and all
kinds of stuff
and his youtube shorts though have
brought massive new exposure and some
people have kind of gone deeper with
them in business and they're having
great results with youtube shorts and he
shares a really powerful strategy on
that so if you see youtube shorts
incorporated into your channel this year
then definitely don't miss that episode
secondly
our 10 most viewed videos on think media
watch this trend out of our 10 most
viewed videos on think media
three were from 2021.
so in the top 10
in 365 day period
only three
were from
last year the year of their publishing
now watch this
three
were from 2020
the previous year
another three were from 2019
and one
was from 2018.
so i'm recording this episode in 2022.
one of the videos in 2021 that was in
the top 10 was from 2018 and and it
received
842 000
new views
just last year alone
so here is the big takeaway under number
two
is that seven were not even seven of our
top ten videos were not even from
this year
youtube is a marathon and not a sprint
and you need to be thinking about
content shelf life and evergreen content
you know i was able to learn from a
youtube employee hearing them speak at
an event and there's an episode where i
shared those insights of course check
out the show notes
a lot of powerful insights but one of
the tips he gave was he said
don't underestimate the power of
evergreen content and ask yourself what
is the content shelf life
of the piece of content that i'm
creating
so i understand that there's a whole
opportunity on youtube to go viral to
talk about in the know
in the now news to talk about trending
headlines
but the shelf life of the that video it
might pop off now and it might be
irrelevant tomorrow there's a whole
other approach
and that is evergreen content and where
that term comes from is you know i'm
recording this in seattle washington
right now we're surrounded by evergreen
trees and that means that when there's
snow in the winter they're still green
it means that when they're sun in the
summer they're still green in spring and
fall these trees are green all year long
and that's the power of youtube it's the
second largest
search engine in the world you have the
chance to create evergreen content
that's relevant today tomorrow
and into the future even for years to
come even to get even a million views on
a video that's a couple years old you
want to talk about the revenue generated
from that video it's incredible and
that's true passive income
and that's true
leverage for building your business
building your channel and this is why we
love youtube the most at the think media
podcast so i would ask yourself what
kind of evergreen content can you create
in 2022
are you thinking about the long game
when it comes to your youtube channel
are you thinking about
um how you can plant seeds today
for the harvest that you want to reap
tomorrow
and
don't get discouraged by your short-term
results our goal is to build a library
of videos that rank in search and
suggested and that keep getting views
for weeks months and years to come so
whether we take a team retreat like we
did around the holidays with the think
media team in las vegas um whether i am
hanging out with my son sean bradley and
we're playing in the snow
whether i'm reading a book or working on
improving our course video ranking
academy when i'm not making videos the
videos i've already made
are working for me
and
todd the youtube employee i believe in
product engineering meaning he's an
engineer at youtube working on the
algorithm and helping us understand the
algorithm
said don't
judge your video by its first day's
performance its first week's performance
or even its first month's performance
don't underestimate the power of
evergreen content and what's interesting
is even the youtube short that we
published proved that same point it did
not go viral on day one or even week one
or even month one but it started to pop
off later
so i want to encourage you this year to
commit to the discipline of creating the
best content possible getting one
percent better with every upload
studying in depth are tips in our
process and this is one thing that the
tube 1k challenge is going to help with
we are going to be teaching five days on
this very thing
because the amount of leverage you get
from evergreen videos that keep getting
views and keep getting subscribers and
keep earning money and then keep
whatever you want to do in your business
if you want to purely make a living as a
youtube entrepreneur or you want to
generate leads get emails get people
calling you
you know get clients grow your financial
services business grow your real estate
business
start you know partner with a network
marketing company and and connect with
people and serve them with products help
them with their health i mean whatever
you actually want to use youtube for
there's never been a better time to be
building your channel uh building a
youtube channel
and so
uh think about evergreen content is
number two and think about the content
shelf life um this year because i want
you to imagine and look ahead
that you know 2018 was now four years
ago
are you thinking
four years ahead right now
in the rush of
hustle and bustle
of 15 second reels tick tocks and
youtube shorts are you thinking four
years ahead friend that's the power of
youtube
and that's why
a lot of people miss youtube because
they miss
and they focus on the short team short
term dopamine hit of some of the other
platforms or they miss the evergreen
strategy on youtube and they focus on
the viral strategy on youtube and
they're trying to be mr beast more power
to you if you can pull that off but
i just can't i obviously get fired up i
could talk about this forever and think
about like larry who's one of our video
ranking academy students he
he has only been on the platform for six
months
um so it's not too late to start youtube
meaning mid 2021 he started from scratch
he's only uploaded 16 videos
and he already has 53 000 subscribers
and almost a million views
he's answering specific questions but
he's focusing on
evergreen content and he's focusing on
making the right videos but here's
what's crazy for larry is even though
he's had that much success in the first
time what happens four years from now
for liberty's channel as he continues to
post videos and work the strategy so
please
this year think about what kind of
evergreen content
and and content that you could create
now that would be relevant four years
from now because by the way the people
watching my video it's still relevant
it's so helpful it's still answering
their question clearly why it's still
getting that many views and so that's
number
two now we're gonna get into number
three but if you love the think media
podcast and watch this on youtube
definitely smash the like button and if
you're on any of the audio platforms my
favorite is spotify where i listen to my
podcasts but you might be on apple
podcast if you leave a review on apple
even if you're a spotify user that means
the world to us
because it really helps us get the word
out about all this information that can
help you build your business and uh
crush it on youtube this year
but number three check this out our most
profitable youtube video
was 44 minutes long
this last year so i studied the top 10
videos and here's your homework
if you've been on youtube even not for a
year but if you've had if you've been on
youtube for a year
go into your youtube analytics select
last year or select the last 365 days
and then right there on the homepage you
have your top 10 videos and then ask
yourself
what can i learn from these what are the
topics what are the thumbnails
what
what are the average view durations
which one made the most money you're
going to figure that out by
going over to your revenue tab and your
youtube analytics selecting the last
year and then looking at which one
earned the most money that's where i
found this and you could dig around your
analytics to study okay
i should do more of that or what can i
learn from that to improve my strategy
going forward
so
the most profitable video though
related to just youtube ad revenue and
we make a lot of we have a lot of income
streams at think media but related to
just youtube ad revenue
was
a from may 2020
so the the money that the video that
earned the most
ad revenue in 2021 was from the year
previous
it earned 15
969 dollars one video
and it didn't even come out
this year so by the way
you're gonna get me back on the content
shelf life and evergreen content point
but how powerful is that now watch them
very high valuable training
we talk about tss teach specific skills
it's actually a video it's about youtube
strategy
but one of the things that we included
in it was five mid roles
and that actually means that there's
multiple ad spots in the video now
let's talk about it
you might watch videos and you go that's
so annoying and you go okay
well
if you really want to watch the content
you're going to watch through it
and i completely empathize with you if
you feel like it's annoying i also think
it's annoying that i have to watch
ads
on hulu and in the middle of yellowstone
on peacock and i need to upgrade my
membership so there's no ads
um and that's what people's option on
youtube is as well because they can pay
for youtube premium or youtube plus or
whatever it's called now and you don't
have ads anymore which by the way the
money still goes to the creator
algorithmically
but why should hulu get so much money
when you the creator if you make an
almost hour-long training
and you teach somebody something that's
super valuable that can change their
life why shouldn't there be a couple ad
spots in it and by the way five mid
rolls in 44 minutes might sound like a
lot but i think that's one you know it's
like every every 10 minutes and one is
at the very very end so you also have to
notice the audience retention curve a
lot of people aren't going to see four
of those or three of those right it's
only if they watch the whole thing um
and another thing you need to know about
youtube ads and youtube mid roles
is that they don't necessarily play so
it doesn't mean that those all five are
going to be quote unquote forced on the
viewer youtube
fires ads triggers ads
with somewhat of a mind of its own
because they want to still protect the
viewer experience to a point so this
just gives you the opportunity to
maximize the amount of ad placements so
again if you're trying to grow your
youtube ad revenue you might think i
need to post 100 videos
and there's one ad at the beginning of
every video or you could post a longer
video here's a huge key that is really
very valuable
and then there could be multiple
multiple ad spots in that video and all
i'm sharing is again trends that we
noticed
one of the things too was that
i went back i i the video did not have
that many ad spots at first
once i had seen that it was proven that
people loved it that it continued to get
views remind you it's over a year old so
here's another tip
what videos can you go back to in your
youtube library now
in a new year
and make changes to them like that can
you say wow this video is performing
well and it only has one ads but i'm
giving away 44 minutes for free hulu
would never do that
and
and and
and someone with youtube premium could
pay to avoid these and then someone who
really wants this like i think about
nolan mult's final cut tutorial on think
media and if you're a final cut 10 user
we have like a two hour class on final
cut for free on youtube think about it
you don't have to pay to buy an online
course you don't have to go to linkedin
learning you don't have to you know get
something you can watch it for free on
youtube and you could either subscribe
to the youtube plus or
you can watch some ad spots every 15
minutes which gives you a chance to have
a break anyways and so anyway this is
not a debate about
whether or not you should do mid roles
if you don't want to that's fine but
keep this in mind
one video
44 minutes long earned almost 16 000
didn't even come out this past year and
it was our most profitable youtube video
which brings us to the question i
promised you earlier
how long should my videos be sean 2022
what is the secret length the secret
sauce the secret answer
of the ideal youtube
video
length
from the data and from the research i
have the answer
should i make long videos or short
videos sean and the answer is
both
the answer is
yes
you should make long videos and short
videos
so let me actually answer that question
with a question
what is the
promise of your channel to the viewer
and
with the video you're gonna post
is that video delivering that value to
the viewer
notice in the top three tips here that i
observed surprising insights from our
channel in 2021 that you can apply going
into 2022
is that
a youtube short was our most viewed
video it grew the channel by a lot
people loved it
it didn't earn a lot of money and then
notice that our most profitable video
was 44 minutes long it got great views
as well
and it earned a lot of money in terms of
youtube ad revenue and so on think media
both videos
were on brand
aligned with the promise of the channel
for the best tips and tools for building
your influence with youtube
and they both delivered value
so as you think about your year i think
youtube
in 2022 gives us an opportunity
to experiment with content formats
content lengths but to be super clear
about the value proposition of the
channel and the promise now when people
come to you they experience an emotion
that when people come to your channel
they experience
a solved problem whether that's
entertainment
whether that's an answer to a question
whether that's a quick tip a quick
insight whether that's a quick
moment of inspiration
and
that might happen
people like to watch compilations of
motivational talks
like my friend lewis howes
has three hour long videos on his
channel
combining
the best clips
of his library of interviews and guests
that he's had
meanwhile
motivational shorts that are 30 seconds
also perform well
and so i want you to be thinking most
about the promise that you're making to
the viewer this year
and be then thinking about
how can i experiment with youtube shorts
how can i experiment what what would i
talk about if i was going to make a
video that was 44 minutes long or am i
going to make a compilation of multiple
things i've done or share a talk that i
did at a workshop or a live stream am i
going to edit a live stream i've done
down in the past make it a little bit
better and then everything in between
how can i do
three-minute videos that are just
traditional
horizontal you know not not vertical
video like a youtube short
should i do five minute videos on my
channel yes
could an eight minute video be good
absolutely there is a trend we notice
that when you go a little bit longer
especially if you're in more of an
education how to
um
people like you know like the thick
media podcast we do longer conversations
here and whatnot
that you definitely have the chance to
get more watch time in general when you
kind of cross over the 10 minute mark
but across the board our our videos are
of all different lengths
great five videos seven is great too
eight is great
13 is great 22 is great here's the rule
your video should be
as short as possible but as long as
necessary
and is necessary just means to convey
the value to tell the story
if you want to be entertaining if you
want to connect with the viewer
stories are powerful but if the story
goes too long and you lose track of
where the person's going it sort of
loses its power doesn't it
the lord of the rings is powerful but
the lord of the rings extended version
is too long all right i just offended
somebody but you know like
sometimes you you want to trim it down
but here's the other thing is i like the
lord of the rings normal virgin tony
ariola on the think media team likes the
extended version
so by giving even your viewers some
people listen to the think media podcast
full length
um some people we use clips from the
think media podcast and we publish those
things other places
so i think this is a major trend in 2022
it's saying how long should content be
yes
it it should be all kinds of lengths you
know and i think that you have the
opportunity to experiment with different
content formats that and that meets
people at different places on their
journey they don't have time to listen
to today's 35-minute episode of the
think media podcast but when we trim out
a clip and post it somewhere else they
get that nugget in three or four minutes
and you ultimately are serving more
people but remember around the same
value proposition you're you're serving
people we help people grow youtube
channels we help you start a channel
grow a channel monetize a channel go
part-time or go ultimately full-time as
a youtube entrepreneur as a content
entrepreneur
uh leveraging youtube as your main
platform and so
take a take a nugget take a deeper dive
training or be a part of the five day
challenge and go five days not even on
youtube we do we host that in a private
facebook group it's all kinds of it's
the same promise but distributed in a
lot of different places to serve you
uh depending on how much time you have
and at what level you want to engage and
you can do the same for your audience
so i hope these three tips help you as
you're creating your 2022 youtube growth
game plan in just a second i've got a
final charge for you as well as the
review
of the day
but i want to remind you that today's
episode is brought to you by tube
chad
the think media team and i realized that
if you really want to grow your youtube
channel sometimes you need
a period of focused intensity where you
really shut out distractions and you
don't just listen to one podcast or
watch a youtube video or consume some
random information but you set aside
some concentrated time to really build
momentum on your channel and we are
doing a free five day challenge seven
total sessions and it's all about how to
get your first 1000 subscribers on
youtube and earn your first 1 000 on
youtube and beyond it's happening
january 24th through the 28th 2022 and
you can register for free at
tube1kchallenge.com
every session we give stuff away cool
tech
tools that will help you create content
plus we're giving away an entire youtube
studio myself tony ariola our vra
director heather torres melissa caputo
are going to be on there we might have
some guest appearances from some of the
other think media team members we have
some students in our community sharing
their insights their surprising insights
for growing their youtube channels um in
some of the sessions as well and it's
going to be absolutely incredible if you
would say i want to stop dabbling on
youtube and i'm ready to start
dominating i want to stop just kind of
being half-hearted in this thing and i
want to go in all in
one of the reasons why it's called a
challenge is because every single day
there's going to be something for you to
do
every day there's going to be something
to learn and there's going to be
something to do and it should be
challenging and so i would encourage you
don't sign up if you
don't want
to really win on youtube and jar
yourself out of the status quo this year
like if you're not ready to just
lean in take notes and not just consume
some information but implementation but
actually apply some of the things you're
learning because we're obsessed friend
we want to help 10 000 purpose-driven
people create a full-time living doing
what they love while making a difference
in the world with
youtube there's never been a better time
to do it than now uh i shared larry's
story earlier it's not too late to start
the creator economy is estimated to by
the end of this year be evaluated at
over a hundred billion dollars that
means there's a piece of that for you on
the other side of taking massive action
so this challenge should be jarring
shocking and it might be a good time to
to shut aside uh to push aside netflix
and peacock and yellowstone um and
selling sunset season four or whatever
we're on now and and just take a few
days imagine just taking a week to build
massive momentum this year that could be
life changing for you your family that
could trigger growth in your channel
help you reach that first milestone or
of a thousand subscribers or grow beyond
that and then scale to the moon because
this is the fastest growing small
business type being a content creator
signal fire
revealed but of course it's also highly
competitive who doesn't want to build a
life in a business on their own terms or
be able to work from home and so you're
going to get tactical actionable
information in this free challenge i
want to encourage you join heather
taurus and i
tube1kchallenge.com as well as the think
media team and uh we can't wait to hang
out with you uh it's on like stream yard
and we will be able to see you uh in the
comments and answer questions it's gonna
be a lot of fun and if you've never been
a part of one you're not gonna want to
miss it it's hard to even describe the
energy
and the
uh experience that
tube1kchallenge.com is the review of the
day
is from upset citizen of earth and they
said this is the only business podcast
that i listen to i love the variety of
business advice you give your podcast
has helped me center my focus on what's
important and a priority for my business
it's amazing how i can listen to the
podcast and watch it on
youtube god
bless you all thank you so much for the
review and i want to encourage you again
if this podcast
encourages you inspires you if you get
tactical information if it's been
helpful if you've been listening if
you've been
uh in the in the back of the room
listening and being taken some notes and
enjoying it but you haven't stepped out
to leave a review that would mean the
world where the world to myself and the
team just to hear your thoughts and your
honest feedback on apple podcast reviews
even if that's not the main platform you
listen to because it helps the podcast
reach more people you know it helps
uh specifically and tactically if you
start even one of your own podcasts
when it's not just downloads but it's
also reviews and the rate of downloads
and reviews that helps the podcast
algorithm determine um uh how the
podcast kind of ranks and how new people
see it and so friend if it would just
take three minutes or less to leave a
quick review that would be incredible i
appreciate you so much and uh
as we land the plane today it's 2022 man
it's time to rise and grind it's time to
punch complacency in the face
it's
time to kick
comparison in the chest
and
really go all in on youtube you know
it might be
a thought that crosses your mind or
someone could say well sean of course
you think it's youtube is the best and
like you know you have a course on
youtube and like you're you have a book
on youtube so you want
you're just trying to get people hyped
on youtube well critics might say that
but my opinion of what's happening on
youtube is irrelevant to the data that
is proving
that this next decade is going to be the
best decade on youtube a recent report
came out about youtube's revenue
compared to netflix's revenue the
streaming wars you got to know youtube's
a player amazon prime netflix youtube
peacock all these platforms
and what is coming in the future of
youtube how do we know that judd's
judged off the past of youtube
right now anything can happen at any
time but right now it just shows us that
youtube is such a juggernaut owned by
google has so much authority and such a
large content library in such a major
technology technological infrastructure
and algorithmically as revealed by not
my opinion but by larry's experience by
so many of our students and ex and
communities experience and by youtube
employees themselves explaining how the
youtube algorithm works friend it is
still practically
a good time to start a youtube channel
the algorithm will still reward new
content on new channels
that is good that has a clear
understanding of who your audience is
and that
is optimized according to what matters
most on youtube and we'll be talking
about that on the challenge so here's
the bottom line
let's go all in man this is our year
this is your year this is your year to
uh cast off distraction to the side and
get super focused on your goals
and build on
youtube youtube is the second largest
search engine in the world 2.3 billion
monthly active users growing 7 out of 10
more accurately 67 of baby boomers are
watching youtube now baby boomers gen x
is blowing up there and gen z and
millennials as well
everyone's watching youtube
tv usage is increasing
mobile usage of course is off the charts
still desktop is super relevant the
algorithm will help you get discovered
and reach people
unl tons of monetization
opportunities on the platform itself and
then
innumerable amounts of business models
you can build around your youtube
channel this is the creator economy
this is 2022 and this is the time to go
all in with the right strategies the
right approach the right mindset and
that's what the think media podcast is
all about so if you haven't subscribed
on youtube and or subscribed on the
audio platforms stick with us all year
man because we're here for you and we
are all about helping you win
on
youtube and build a real business
and experience real success without
losing your soul build a really healthy
paced healthy business that's not just
based on trends but that's based on real
business principles real service real
community real value real depth and real
sustainable
youtube strategies as we've seen videos
from years ago still growing we want to
teach you how to do that so make sure
you subscribe to the podcast and if you
want a jump start a shot in the arm a
kick in the pants an espresso shot
in your
oat milk then do not miss
thetube1kchallenge.com my name is sean
cannell i appreciate you this is the
think media podcast and until next time
keep crushing it and i will
hang with you soon on the next episode
peace